la commission d'enquêté sénatoriale sur
la lutte contre le jihad rattrapés par
l'actualité alors que les sénateurs
poursuivre en ce moment même à leur
audition
un deuxième français après le normand
maximo chars a été identifiée sur la
vidéo diffusée par l'état islamique qui
met en scène la décapitation de 18,6
rien et de l'otage américain peter
casting sophie normand couturier il
s'appelle michael i do santos après le
normand maximo charrie lille second
français identifié parmi les bourreaux
du groupe death un jeune homme de 22 ans
originaires de champigny sur marne
converti lui aussi je pense à la famille
je pense évidemment victimes là bas mais
je pense à sa famille proche de son nom
de guerre abou ousman le jeune homme
apparaît dans la vidéo qui met en scène
la décapitation de 18 prisonniers si
riant et de l'otage américain peter k
sig
une vidéo qui pose une fois de plus la
question des réseaux jihadistes
la problématique est au coeur de
l'actualité du sénat une commission d'
enquête sur l'organisation et les moyens
de lutter contre a démarré début octobre
avec de nombreuses interrogations en
suspens essayez de comprendre de façon
rationnelle
comment ces jeunes gens peuvent
fonctionner comment ils se convertissent
pourquoi ils se convertissent comment on
peut essayer d'enrayer lusage d'internet
qui est le pourvoyeur de djihadistes
évidemment sans sombrer dans les lois
liberticides
alors que par ailleurs la loi ne peut
pas tout faire tout ça est un travail de
grands équilibristes pour l'instant nous
nous rassemblons les pièces du puzzle
les auditions de personnalités
concernées par le dossier devrait se
poursuivre jusqu'en février mars avant
un rapport attendu en avril